>> A MEMORIAL EVENT FOR DAVID
HAMBURG, SPEAKER PELOSI AND I
HAD A CHANCE TO DISCUSS
IMPEACHMENT.
MR. DEAN, WHO WROTE THAT?
>> I DID.
>> HAVEN'T WE BEEN TOO LONG --
WHO WROTE THAT?
>> I ASSUME IT WAS MINE.
>> WE ARE WITNESSING TRUMP'S
MASSIVE COVER-UP.
HE'S INCAPABLE OF ACCOMPLISHING
ANYTHING.
YOU KNOW WHO WROTE THAT?
>> I SUSPECT IT WAS ME AGAIN.
>> IT WAS YOU.
>> Laura: HE SHOULD'VE SAID
THAT WAS I.
IT'S JUST GRAMMATICAL STUFF.
TODAY THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
LESSONS FROM THE MUELLER REPORT.
THROUGHOUT THE SPECTACLE, DEAN
REVEALED NOTHING MORE THAN A
GROSSLY BIASED MEMBER OF THE
RESISTANCE.
BEFORE THE HEARING BEGAN, HE
APPEARED ON HIS NEW HOME, CNN,
AND ADMITTED HE WOULDN'T BE
ESTABLISHING ANYTHING NEW OR
EVEN RELEVANT.
>> CLEARLY NOT A FACT WITH THIS
BUT I HOPE I CAN GIVE THE SOME
CONTEXT AND SHOW THEM HOW
STRIKINGLY LIKE WATERGATE WHAT
WE ARE SEEING NOW AND IS
REPORTED IN THE MUELLER REPORT
IS.
>> Laura: WHAT THE HECK WAS
THE POINT OF THIS ENTIRE
EXERCISE ON CAPITOL HILL?
YOU KNOW, THE MAN YOU JUST SAW,
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN, MEMBER
OF THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
FORMER DEPUTY ATTORNEY ASSISTANT
JOHN U.
HOW COULD THE DEMS THINK THAT
THIS WAS GOING TO ADVANCE ANY
NARRATIVE?
IT WAS A P.R. STUNT.
I'M SURPRISED THEY DIDN'T TRY TO
LEVITATE OTHER PEOPLE FROM THE
WATERGATE ERA OUT OF THE GRAVE.
BUT WHAT DID THEY ACCOMPLISH?
BIG I DON'T KNOW IF THEY
ACCOMPLISH ANYTHING BUT THIS IS
THEIR PATTERN.
FIRST WITNESS OF CONGRESS, THEIR
FIRST ANNOUNCED WITNESS WAS
MICHAEL COHEN.
HE WENT TO PRISON FOR LYING TO
CONGRESS.
THEY BROUGHT THEM IN FRONT OF
CONGRESS AND NO SURPRISE HE LIED
AGAIN.
THEY BRING IN JOHN DEAN AND JOHN
DEAN PLED GUILTY TO OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE.
THIS IS THEIR PATTERN AND IT'S
ALL ABOUT THEM TRYING TO GET THE
PRESIDENT.
NEVER FORGET THE KEY CHAIRMAN IN
THE HOUSE HAD THE MEMORANDUMS OF
UNDERSTANDING.
ACTUAL CONTRACTS THEY HAD
WRITTEN AMONG THEMSELVES.
THIS IS HOW WERE GOING TO HAVE
OUR EFFORT TO GET THE PRESIDENT.
MICHAEL COHEN, JOHN DEAN, ALL
THIS IS WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO
AND THEY WON'T CALL IT
IMPEACHMENT BUT THAT'S FRANKLY
WHAT IT IS IN THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE KNOW IT'S WRONG.
>> Laura: JOHN, DEAN WAS ON
CNN TONIGHT AGAIN TRYING TO DRAW
THE PATHETIC PARALLELS TO
WATERGATE.
WHY IS HE WRONG?
>> IF YOU WANTED TO HAVE AN
EXPERT ON HOW TO COMMIT
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE, THEY
BROUGHT THE EXPERT INCOME A GUY
WHO PLED GUILTY TO IT.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I GUESS WERE GOING TO CALL
BILL CLINTON THAT'S WHEN THEY
START THE IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS
AS THEIR FIRST WITNESS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP COMPARED TO THE
NIXON ADMINISTRATION, WATERGATE,
TRUMP MADE ALL HIS OFFICIALS
AVAILABLE.
DID NOT EXERCISE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
MADE ALL THE EMAILS AND
DOCUMENTS AVAILABLE.
IF YOU WANTED TO DRAW A CONTRAST
BETWEEN WATERGATE AND THE
MUELLER REPORT, YOU COULDN'T
HAVE DONE BETTER THAN ACTUALLY
BRING JOHN DEAN TO TESTIFY.
>> Laura: YEAH.
HE KIND OF LOOKS LIKE MR. GREEN
JEANS FROM CAPTAIN KANGAROO.
MR. GREEN JEANS IS HERE.
HE WAS I THINK REFERENCING YOU
TONIGHT.
HE WAS ON CNN.
OTHERS WHO ARE CRITICIZING HIS
PARENTS, CONGRESSMAN.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WERE YOU TAKEN ABACK AT ALL
BY HOW PERSONAL SOME OF THE
ATTACKS BY REPUBLICANS WORK?
DID YOU EXPECT THE HEARING TO BE
AS CONTENTIOUS AS IT WAS?
>> I DID ACTUALLY.
I KNOW THE PLAYERS.
I WATCH THEM BEFORE.
I HAVE WATCH THEM BADGER
HILLARY CLINTON.
THEY ARE ALL FLAMETHROWERS.
>> Laura: I DON'T SEE THE
FLAMETHROWER PART.
>> I DIDN'T BADGER
HILLARY CLINTON.
I BROUGHT UP FACTS, THE FACT
THAT SHE WANTED TO BLAME THE
TRAGEDY IN BENGHAZI ON THE
VIDEO.
WE ALL KNEW SHE KNEW WHAT WAS
WRONG WHICH TALKED ABOUT THAT.
THE PRESIDENT WAS FALSELY
ACCUSED OF CONSPIRING WITH
RUSSIAN --
>> Laura: WHERE'S THE
CURIOSITY?
WHY WOULDN'T SOMEONE LIKE JOHN
DEAN ESPECIALLY BE CONCERNED
ABOUT IT?
STIGLER EXACTLY THE POINT.
FALSELY ACCUSED.
AND THEN BOB MILLER DUSTY 22
MONTH INVESTIGATION AND SAYS NO
COLLUSION AND THERE'S NO
INDICTMENT ON OBSTRUCTION.
IF THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO SAY
LET'S KEEP LOOKING AT THAT
VERSUS LOOKING AT THE FALSE
ACCUSATIONS STARTED THE WHOLE
THING.
TO ME, THAT'S THE BIG PROBLEM
HERE.
AGAIN, JOHN DEAN, HERE'S THE
OTHER CONNECTION WITH
MICHAEL COHEN VERY JOHN DEAN WAS
GIVING ADVICE TO LANNY DAVIS,
MICHAEL COHEN'S LAWYER.
THE NIGHT BEFORE MICHAEL COHEN
IS SUPPOSED TO COME TESTIFY,
JOHN DEAN IS ON CNN, PAID
CONTRIBUTOR TO CNN, AND HE SAYS
I TOLD LEN DAVIS TELL YOUR
CLIENT, TELL MICHAEL COHEN NOT
TO GIVE TESTIMONY TO THE
REPUBLICANS.
ACTUALLY OBSTRUCT THE
INVESTIGATION OF THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE THAT'S WHAT HE TOLD
THEM.
HE'S AN EXPERT ON OBSTRUCTION.
HE WAS ADVISING MICHAEL COHEN TO
DO THAT WHEN HE CAME TO TESTIFY
FOUR MONTHS AGO.
MICHAEL COHEN FOLLOWED HIS
ADVICE AND HE ALSO LIED.
>> Laura: IT'S BECOME THE
RESISTANCE MEETING.
THIS IS CNN.
JAMES EARL JONES, WHERE DOES HE
GO TO GET HIS VOICE-OVER BACK?
IN THE LETTER TO SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, STEPHEN
BOYD OFFERED MORE DETAILS ON
BARR'S INVESTIGATION INTO THE
SURVEILLANCE AND THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, DESCRIBING IT AS BROAD
IN SCOPE AND MULTIFACETED.
HOW SIGNIFICANT IS THE LANGUAGE?
>> I THINK IT'S TREMENDOUSLY
SIGNIFICANT.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE JUST ONE
REVIEW OF A SINGLE FISA
APPLICATION.
LET ME POINT OUT CONGRESSMAN
JORDAN HAS DONE GREAT WORK
BRINGING TO LIGHT A LOT OF THESE
SHENANIGANS THAT WERE GOING ON
AT THE VERY START OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
I'M NOT SURPRISED
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR IS GOING
TO CONDUCT A BROAD INVESTIGATION
BECAUSE I HATE TO SAY IT, MY
FORMER COLLEAGUES IN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, THE MORE WE LEARN
ABOUT HOW THIS STARTED, THE
WORSE IT'S GOING TO GET.
IT'S AN OBLIGATION OR DUTY OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN.
SOMETHING LIKE THE
STEELE DOSSIER COULD SET US OFF
ON A TWO-YEAR HUNT TO TEAR DOWN
THE CONSTITUTION.
>> Laura: JUSTIN AMASH IS
STEPPING DOWN?
>> WE HAD A FUN MEETING WITH
JUSTIN, THE BOARD OF THE FREEDOM
CAUCUS, THE CHAIRMAN AND
MR. AMASH WILL BE TALKING AT
THAT.
WE STRONGLY DISAGREE WITH HIM.
THEY WILL BE TALKING ABOUT THE
SITUATION TOMORROW.
>> Laura: DO YOU HAVE A LOT OF
FRIENDS WHO THINK LIKE JUSTIN
AMASH?
>> WE DON'T, AND HE'S WRONG.
>> Laura: HE IS TRYING TO
DESTROY THIS PRESIDENCY UNDER
FALSE PRETENSES.
>> TOTALLY WRONG I TOTALLY
DISAGREE WITH HIS ASSESSMENT.
>> Laura: IS HE GOING TO RUN
FOR THE NOMINATION?